il y a quelques jours vous avez franchi
la barre des 500 milles abonnés sur
youtube
c'est énorme jamais je n'ai pensé que ça
irait aussi vite
un grand merci donc à vous toutes et
tous qui m'a accompagné dans cette
aventure et m'encourager avec vos
messages et vos commentaires pour fêter
ça j'ai donc décidé de réaliser une
vidéo est facturé pris un énorme plaisir
à vous lire j'espère que les réponses
seront à la hauteur on va passer dans
l'atelier place à vos questions allez
c'est parti dit jamie qu'est ce que tu
voulais faire comme métier quand tu
étais petit bien quand j'étais petit à
petit ça a commencé à l'âge de 10-12 ans
je voulais devenir journaliste
j'allais en colonie de vacances est en
colonie de vacances il fallait faire un
journal est bien le fun à tour de rôle
mais j'adorais cet exercice et j'étais
prêt à échanger cette corvée contre
d'autres faire la vaisselle par exemple
j'adorais raconter d'histoires j'avais
réécrire et un jour je me suis dit ce
serait merveilleux d'en faire mon métier
j'ai cette chance de pouvoir lui
raconter des histoires déjà mis c'est
sympa se ferment tu t'amuses en le
faisant
non c'est extrêmement triste évidemment
que oui je m'amuse d'abord quand j'écris
je prends plaisir à apprendre
donc ça c'est premier effet kiss cool
ensuite je prends plaisir et je m'amuse
à le mettre en scène avec la petite
caméra quand on imagine les maquettes
quand on trouve les objets que l'on va
détourner pour faire une maquette et
vous imaginez
bien aussi que pendant les tournages on
s'amuse beaucoup surtout quand un objet
de reprendre une vidéo
dix fois parce que ma langue a fourché
et que je n'arrive pas à l'équipe
n'était pas toute la pub plutôt la fée
plaintes des pains de glace qui sont au
dessus des buts
moi ça me fait moins rire général
ça l'amusé beaucoup dit jamie qui se
cache derrière la petite caméra et bien
derrière cette caméra il y à manuela
c'est mon épouse ce projet a vu le jour
pendant le conflit mans et pendant le
confinement et bien nous n'étions que
deux ici dans cet atelier est dans le
jardin alors madonna s'occupe d'elle
images mais également du son et elle est
douée et je peux même pas vous la
présenter puisque là en ce moment elle
est derrière la caméra avec le casque
sur les oreilles dit jamais une petite
vidéo sur les volcans de la chaîne des
puys est ce envisageable
évidemment vous savez j'adore les
volcans et j'ai hâte d'aller arpenter la
chaîne des puys avec la petite caméra
pour vous raconter leur formation déjà
mais quels sont tes sources de
documentation pour préparer des vidéos
alors je suis journaliste à la base pour
préparer ces vidéos j'utilise tous les
moyens qu'ils utilisent
traditionnellement les journalistes les
livres j'en ai pas mal au dessus de ma
tête une bibliothèque dans laquelle on
trouve énormément de
livres de science de pédagogie et puis
j'utilise aussi les journaux les
magazines que je lis régulièrement
j'écoute aussi beaucoup la radio pas mal
de podcasts autour des sujets
scientifiques puis les sites internet
évidemment qu'ils traitent des sujets
que j'aborde dans mes vidéos et
l'essentiel c'est de croiser les
informations quand je lis quelque chose
qui ne colle pas que j'ai un petit doute
et bien j'essaie de retrouver cette
information explique est confirmée par
une autre source
ça c'est mon boulot de journaliste dit
jamie a tué un livre à nous conseiller
quand c'est difficile de conseiller un
livre un roman années ces essais pour
les vacances oui j'ai un livre à vous
conseiller un livre que j'ai adoré
magellan de stefan zweig qui raconte
l'épopée du navigateur au xvième siècle
le premier navigateur à avoir fait le
tour du monde
voilà c'est le premier à avoir imaginé
qu entre l'europe et l'asie
il y avait un continent l'amérique parce
que je rappelle que lorsque christophe
colomb découvre l'amérique une pensée
landes
c'est une magnifique histoire et le lire
pendant les vacances c'est vraiment le
moment idéal
alors oui il y a aussi des experts j'en
ai une liste longue comme mon bras
depuis une trentaine d'années dès que je
veux vérifier quelque chose et ça
m'arrive très souvent que je consulte
ses experts même lorsque j'explique
quelque chose que j'ai déjà expliqué
auparavant je veux m'assurer que ça n'a
pas changé parce que la science évolue
même lorsqu'on explique des principes de
base déjà mis c'est toi qui fais les
maquettes pour chaque vidéo où ce sont
des objets que tu achètes je vais vous
faire une confidence je suis nul en
bricolage ces manuels à qui les
fabriquent
on les conçoit ensemble on conçoit les
maquettes les décors souvent je fais des
petits croquis et manuela les fabricants
suite alors pour ça elle utilise des
objets que nous avons autour de nous et
très souvent d'ailleurs elle détourne
les objets au début c'était un peu une
obligation parce que pendant le
confinement tous les magasins où nous
aurions pu nous approvisionner été
fermées donc il fallait trouver d'autres
solutions
ce saladier par exemple a été transformé
en 2000 club et je suis sûr qu'avec ses
talents elle aurait pu aussi le
transformer en casque le corps de la
fusée a été réalisé à partir d'une boîte
d'amuse-gueule des pringles
et si vous regardez bien vous voyez sous
la peinture bleue un petit peu de rose
tout simplement parce que avant d'être
une fusée cette botte de pringles a été
une trachée qui m'a servi à expliquer
comment fonctionnaient les cordes
vocales au dessus voilà
les tâches supérieur a été réalisé à
partir d'une petite burette d'huile qui
appartenait à mon père on vit on recycle
aussi pas mal quand on fait des
maquettes
vous pourriez faire un livre sur ce que
vous avez fait pendant le confinement
est bien ce livre est en cours
d'écriture
j'en suis à peu près à la moitié il
devrait sortir au mois de novembre et
c'est un livre dans lequel est bien je
reprend tous les thèmes que j'ai abordé
au cours des cinquante cinq jours de
confinement alors on y retrouve les
textes des capsules mais aussi beaucoup
de choses que je n'ai pas eu le temps de
vous dire à propos de ces sujets parce
que en une minute je ne pouvais pas tout
vous raconter et puis et puis vous allez
retrouver à l'intérieur de ce livre est
bien des images des dessins qui sont
réalisés par la petite caméra où l'on
retrouve tous les décors que nous avons
utilisée pour illustrer les phénomènes
que j'ai décrit à travers ses capsules
non ce n'est pas mon grand père qui a
inspiré hergé pour créer le personnage
du professeur tournesol c'est le grand
père de bertrand piccard est l'inventeur
du solar impulse avait cet avion solaire
qui a fait le tour de la planète
bertrand piccard a également fait le
tour de la planète en ballon et c'est
son grand-père auguste piccard qui a été
le premier à monter dans la stratosphère
en ballon
quinze mille mètres d'altitude c'est ce
scientifique qui a inspiré hergé
un scientifique qui avait déminé trombe
as-tu déjà pensé à devenir prof ou à
enseigner non je n'y ai jamais pensé
parce que le métier d'enseignant est
très différent c'est un métier complexe
bien sûr je transmets toi je vais
pousser
j'en ai marre de retraités feuilles des
frondes s'agissant des fougères et je
suis un passeur je suis entre ceux qui
détiennent le savoir et ceux qui veulent
l'acquérir
un peu comme les enseignants mais je ne
le fais pas du tout dans le même cadre
je ne fais à travers
un petit écran sur des livres d'une
manière de vous divertir sous forme de
spectacles de loisirs alors qu'un
enseignant lui il est là pour aussi
avoir des résultats
faire en sorte qu'après ces cours les
choses soient rentrés dans nos petites
têtes et qu'on soit en mesure de
répondre aux questions qui seront posées
lors d'un exercice ou lors d'un examen
moi je ne vous pose jamais question déjà
mais quand tu faire des capsules sur
l'astronomie
évidemment j'ai énormément de choses à
vous raconter sur ce qui se passe au
dessus de nos têtes sur nos étoiles le
soleil en particulier les trous noirs
etc etc
il ya une actualité extrêmement riche
dans ce domaine et je compte bien vous
en faire profiter son partir dans
l'espace dit jamie penses-tu faire
d'autres formats que le monde de jamie
ou les capsules à la télé ou sur youtube
alors évidemment il ya toujours des
projets dans les tuyaux mais pour le
moment rien de concret en ce qui
concerne la télévision durera donc
toujours le monde de jamie en revanche
en ce qui concerne youtube pour le
moment il ya chez jany mais promis à
partir de la rentrée de nouveaux formats
vont arriver c'est encore un petit peu
tôt pour vous en parler dit jamais
pourquoi continue à nous apprendre de
nouvelles choses pourquoi tu ne profites
pas de ta retraite tranquillement nommé
oh c'est pas parce que j'ai de la barbe
blanche que je prends ma retraite je
n'ai que 56 ans je fais du sport je fais
attention à mon alimentation je me porte
très bien et je compte bien vous
raconter des histoires pendant encore
très très longtemps pourquoi je continue
mais tout simplement parce que ça me
plaît ça m'amuse sam épanouie ce n'est
pas un effort quand je me lève le matin
j'ai qu'une idée en tête c'est apprendre
quelque chose
il prend du plaisir et ensuite faire en
sorte que les autres puissent aussi
prendre du plaisir donc donc je
prendrais du plaisir
vous en prendrez
j'ai pas l'intention de m'arrêter demain
dit jamie je pense que c'est une
question qu'on te pose souvent est
est-ce que tu es encore à mener avec
fred
évidemment avec freine avec sabine alors
bien sûr on se voit beaucoup moins
souvent qu'auparavant ne travaillent
plus ensemble depuis maintenant sept ans
chacun a continué de son côté fred a
créé son site sa chaîne sur youtube
l'esprit sorcier s'abîme elle toujours
journaliste elle fait des spectacles
autour du fonctionnement des orchestres
symphoniques des orchestres de chambre
mais régulièrement s'appelle pour
prendre des nouvelles des uns et des
autres et comme on est souvent aussi par
monts et par vaux
c'est vrai que c'est un peu difficile de
se croiser mais régulièrement on
s'appelle dis jamais tu compte reprendre
quand le rythme de vidéos normale en
principe à partir du mois de septembre
s'est octroyé avec la petite caméra un
petit peu de repos donc une vidéo tous
les quinze jours
mais à partir de début septembre on
devrait reprendre notre rythme
hebdomadaire mieux que ça dans les
semaines qui vont suivre qu'il devrait
aussi avoir de nouveaux formats sur
youtube
j'espère que vos passions très jusque-là
déjà mais quels seront les prochains
reportage dans le monde de jamie est en
seront ils diffusent et il me semble que
le prochain monde de jamie sera
consacrée aux inondations il sera
diffusé vraisemblablement à la rentrée
entre le mois de septembre et le mois de
novembre je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus c'est une super émission avec des
effets spéciaux assez spectaculaire on a
également une émission sur les incendies
de forêt elle est quasiment terminée une
autre sur le langage des animaux alors
ça c'est extraordinaire aussi j'ai eu la
chance de plonger avec des dauphins
attention pas n'importe quel plonger un
pas une plongée agressive je me suis
immergé dans l'eau et avec des experts
et j'ai laissé les dauphins veut
il y avait 1 - c'est eux qui ont décidé
et non pas moi et je me suis retrouvé au
milieu d'un brouhaha à plusieurs
reprises j'ai fait une dizaine de
plongée c'est complètement dingue de se
sentir observé scanner par des dauphins
et puis on a d'autres sujets en
préparation il ya quelques jours
vous m'avez peut-être vu accroché à la
paroisse de l'aiguillé du midi à
chamonix
ça c'est une émission qui sera consacré
à la montagne face au réchauffement
voyez ça donne envie si jamais si tu
avais un message à faire passer pour
toute la génération actuelle que
serait-il soyez curieux
posez vous des questions quand vous
voyez quelque chose
interrogez-vous est allé chercher la
réponse quand vous aurez la réponse
faites en sorte de la course voire de
bien la comprendre et vous verrez que
comprendre le monde qui nous entoure est
extrêmement épanouissant oui j'ai
quelques objets autour de moi comment
cette plante une fougère qui n'a pas de
fleurs se reproduit eh bien ça nous
permet de plonger dans l'histoire du
temps dans l'histoire de la végétation
puisque les fougères figurent parmi les
premières plantes qui ont colonisé une
planète
elles se reproduisent avec des
tout-petits corpuscules on appelle des
sports n'y a pas de fleurs avec cette
plante c'est avant les fleurs dont
courrier cette simple plante nous permet
de faire un bond dans le temps
extraordinaires avec ce caillou ce
caillou c'est une roche volcanique c'est
ce qu'on appelle une bonne et bien pour
savoir comment il s'est formé pour
savoir d'où il vient
on rentre aussi dans l'histoire de notre
planète et puis cette fusée qui n'est
qu'une maquette et bien dès l'instant on
se pose la question sur la manière dont
elle s'arrache du sol eh bien on
comprend certaines lois de la physique
et puis quand on comprend comment une
capsule peut être
il en orbite autour de notre planète
comment la station spatiale
internationale peut être mise en orbite
comment un objet à 400 kilomètres au
dessus de nos têtes tournent sans
activer des moteurs eh bien ce sont des
lois de la physique qui sont
épanouissante à comprendre
donc voilà je vous conseille de vous
poser des questions et d'avoir envie de
comprendre le monde qui nous entoure je
vous promets que même dans les moments
qui sont les plus durs dans la vie quand
on s'accroche à des choses comme ça eh
bien ce sont de vrais lumière des phares
qui nous invite à continuer à aller
encore plus loin
bonnes vacances la petite caméra et
jamais c'est très sympa bonnes vacances
à vous aussi
et revenir en forme ciao
[Musique]